I have to stay for work father I never  see here your life is happening now  right in front of you I'm sorry what to  do what to do what to do indeed Oh  Christopher Robin you're here in London  I haven't seen you in years  lost all of my friends we need to find  them oh are you an expedition Oh mother  look what can't see moving and talking  but why just try and be elastic suberin  to you looks too bright to pay a nap  time I love play well it sees like this  well duh  [Music]  house clouds train boat waiting oh  please say what you see Oh could you say  what you see a little more quietly house  grass  [Music]  Christopher Robin he's giant oh and he  smells a little funny  [Applause]  [Music]  just an average Wednesday morning walk  it's always a sunny day when Christopher  Robin comes to place a layover Disney's  Christopher Robin rated PG get tickets  now  [Music]